1010 we'll get started
before I before I start today I just
want to make an announcement um that um
and you'll see in your calendars this
Friday but that the speaker um announced
yesterday and that is that um he's
appointed me chair of the committee and
Fred ducet as Vice chair of the
committee going forward
so thank you yes join thank
you all right now getting on with the
business of the day we'll start with the
public hearing on hb1 1410 and I'll ask
representative Tony leas to come
up
yes um does that is there another member
being appointed to the committee
or um not at the present time uh
representative Sanborn will stay on the
committee as a Committee Member thank
you that
clarifies okay thank you um I'm
representative Tony leus representing uh
the District of Hillsboro 38 the towns
of Hudson and Lichfield and I'm
introducing House Bill 1410 what I want
uh want to make a note first of all I
noticed that uh after we amended it
there was a revised fiscal note but the
ones sitting out here don't have that um
I don't know what the committee has but
the uh uh the revenue reduction is
dramatically less after the amendment um
you know that the house made recently it
accepted from
Edna um I don't think we
have and it's um yes represent it's said
it on the top it's uh amended 229 from
the
LBA at the top of the fiscal
note I don't I don't know if we have
here it is I printed it from the State
website
yesterday representative use your
microphone please they might have
changed changed the amendment number
when they put it into the calendar the
amendment had a person's name on it they
put it for the the diff the difference
is the fiscal note has different numbers
in it the one that I have versus what's
sitting on the table out here just I
didn't know which one you folks were
looking at oh
dear I have one that that says
22924 okay and the number for 2024 in
Revenue reduction is
23825 to zero but if so that's the new
one okay thank you I just want to make
sure okay so um this bill as amended
does a number of things it uh it makes
various uh changes kind of uh followup
on some things that were missed in uh
kind of the changes for occupational
licensing last year but the change that
has a fiscal impact is removal of the
licensing of of the registration of
medical
technicians and committee did that
because that whole thing is basically
dysfunctional I mean director Courtney
can give you more details if you like
but um nobody was interest wasn't
serving on the board the board never met
as a result they couldn't create any
rules I mean there it was completely
couldn't function at all and um and so
it's being eliminated and as a result
according to the fiscal note they're
going to uh you know not take in the uh
registration
fees and um there'll be some minor
reduction work but it says it's not
going to reduce costs but uh if you have
questions about the details of why we
did it or you know that aspect of the
bill I'll be glad to answer it but uh
just to get further clarification on the
on the number if we look at the last
page you were saying the medical
technicians number of
23825 excuse me um on the last page of
the bill yeah where at the bottom the
where it says Revenue in the the in the
table um for FY 2024 it says 23825 to
zero depending on when the Bill's
passed
the
last the last page of the I mean it's
the last page of the
fiscal I can bring this up if you want
to take a look at it if that would
help this is the new one yours yeah I I
think the the difficulty here is that
we're some of us have one fiscal Noe and
others have the other F I mean the new
one the numbers are around I think a
tenth as much or something go mine which
came off off also out
of mine which came out of uh two nights
ago I think it was the um
internet on is labeled LBA 24
2690 and amended
22924 yours was the original fiscal note
the the what I'm looking at is something
that was on our desk this
morning right and I noticed the ones
that are set out today here on the table
are the old one oh they are they have
the old fiscal note yeah okay yeah she
she missed that it had been
changed so you you have the only copy of
the new fiscal note then yeah I just
brought one for myself okay all right
we'll have to a
copy you have a copy of you have a copy
of it yeah can I see that for a
second that's because I went to the
internet to download all these bills
yeah so I could read them before
today sort of read
them
and if you could uh just um tell us
briefly again why the huge decrease
there okay the original Bill eliminated
the licensing of uh of uh lnas licensed
nursing assistants because they uh
there's also a federal registration
program and the thought was that they
could just be in that program and not
require a separate license I mean we
need more of them they're not paid a lot
and we want to reduce the cost and the
trouble to them but it turned out there
was a problem
um the issue what we couldn't get rid of
that one at least at that time because
um the growing number of them are are
hired by families to work in people's
homes and if we just had the federal
legislation under the rules for that we
could not require a background check um
and that you know was felt that that
could be a problem um I speaking with
director Courtney there may be a way
around it that can actually be done
without legislation but you can ask her
about that I don't have the details and
the other one was um it it got rid of
the licensing for um Medical Imaging um
technicians and there's a lot more of
those in the lnas than there are of the
the regular medical technicians which
remained in the bill and so the number
of Li of people being
licensed um that would be removed
reduced was a much smaller number than
the original bill which is why the
impact is less okay
questions representative
Ellery I'll get the question out early
so that the commissioner can respond
when she gets up here um will the agency
opl or damn initials um have the ability
to continue to function effectively with
reduced pay
in um you you can I I'm not the one to
answer that question
why that's why I asked you so somebody
else could hear
okay representative
elme
oh I don't know if this is proper
here but are we going to do anything
about
MedEx um which are the people that that
guy that poisoned yeah I'm familiar with
yeah there was a problem with hepatitis
C if I recall correctly yeah um
I I don't know what is going to be done
in the future um this isn't working U
maybe you know in the future some other
way of handling it can be found but they
all work in medical facilities that or
the medical facilities are licensed I
believe or at least you know they have
an employer who should be overseeing
what's going on they're not out uh
practicing on their
own but um you know there wasn't a a
solution that might work that was
suggested um while we were dealing with
the
Bill thank
you anybody yes representative elberger
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you for
taking my question I'm trying to figure
out how to phrase some of
this assuming that this uh
board the the board that deals with the
licensed medical technicians is no
longer looking at people in that
profession what kind of education or
other requirements or skills will be
examined and by whom to make sure that
those folks are
actually competent to do the work that
they're being asked to do I understand
um first of all it's registration for
them not licens that's fine and second
of all because U they could never get
more than one person to serve on the
board the never had a quum it couldn't
meet it couldn't create rules so it
never had any requirements at all uh but
what you know existed before and has
been going on and would continue is that
you know their employer which is a
medical facility would have some
requirements for if they're going to
hire them um but medical technician is I
mean they're
not it's a wide range of Things director
Courtney might be able to give you a
better idea but it's basically anybody
who has access to patients and might
have access to drugs not that they could
supposed to be handling them but they
might be in the same room with them and
that includes people that like clean the
O and clean the ER and it's a range of
things so there's not going to be one
set of
training uh for them at least that's my
understanding Mr
chairman um followup followup so in what
you're saying is that the responsibility
for making sure that the people who are
hired in these roles are competent and
safe and all of that will be the people
who hire them not some Outside Agency
correct that's my understanding yeah
thank you and again director Courtney
might be able to fill in some more
details anybody else seeing none thank
you very much thank
you let's the updated FAL not okay next
uh the next pin card I have is uh
um
uh L I'm having trouble reading it Lind
Lindsay
leli sorry for butchering the
name uh thank you Mr chair members of
the committee I am Lindsay Cy I'm the
executive director of The Office of
professional license insurance
certification um we are not uh taking a
position on this bill but I'm here to
offer and answer any questions that you
may have regarding specifically the
financial impact but as well as the
policy underpinings of this bill um in
terms of uh whether we can absorb the
decrease in Revenue I would say yes um
this historically this registration was
created back in
2015 it's not an actual profession um as
representative lakas mentioned it's just
anybody who is not licensed who may come
into contact with controlled drugs and
paat
and so it's somewhat vague somewhat
difficult to Define um and as a result
of that uh people don't feel like they
want to participate in the board this
has been our understanding um because
it's not a profession that has specific
requirements specific training um it's
just anybody who may come into contact
with drugs so they have not had a quorum
in over two years have not had a meeting
in over two years um and the decision
was made um to essentially repeal the
registration requirement
because they have not had meetings there
has not been a lot of Staff support and
because it's a strict registration there
has not been a lot of Staff support the
fee that was charged was previously
required by Statute so there was no
opportunity to modify that fee um and so
what I would say to your question
representative Willer is yes we can
definitely absorb the decrease in
Revenue I'd be Happ to answer any other
questions that you may have but that's
the gist of it thank you representative
ery to assuage just this is a Policy Act
actual question but just to assuage some
concern that may
exist each one of the facilities that
hires one of these individuals would
then if registration ceases would then
be responsible for establishing the
policies and procedures to any
individual coming in contact with uh any
kind of
medicine and then the liability would
shift from the re registrant to the
facility yes it's typically required as
part of their accreditation um the
accrediting bodies usually require at
least suspicious based testing for
example if there's concerns about
diversion this is the issue that this
particular registration was trying to
capture the other thing that the policy
committee considered was the fact that
we've had registra but because we
haven't had a quorum even if we have
received complaints which we have we
have not been able to actually remove
people from the registry and actually
notify the public of harm because
there's been no board to function so
practically it's been completely
dysfunctional and hasn't been operating
that's what the policy committee also
considered thank you
commissioner any other
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank you for your
time I have no other pink cards is there
anyone else who would like to testify on
hb1
1410 okay seeing none I'll close the um
public hearing on hp1
1410 have three
minutes
e
oh representative Aly um when obviously
when you get a chance no rush fill out a
pink card
please right on in the absence of the
Prime sponsor representative Popovich
Muller
on
no
well on on I'm opening the house bill
1655 uh and um have nothing to say about
it except that I think representative
fellows has something to say about it
thank
you
okay representative
fellows um yes uh I've read this bill
and um um also just to let you know I
worked at the Department of Education
for 32 years and so I'm familiar with um
a lot of their
operations the this bill the first
section of this
bill adds to the
responsibilities um this this this
section the first part the section
that's being amended is actually Ru
making so it's adding to the department
the um process
of um doing criminal history record
checks for people who apply for
certification usually is teachers but it
could be any kind of employee of a
school district and that's something
that people have been asking for for
quite a while because it's a kind of
tedious process for the SAU try to
trying to do that if they have one
person who who can do that at the
department that would be
great the second part starting with line
11 has to do with
creating um a new fund a
non-aps fund and what's interesting
about this is that they already have
such a fund it's been exist in existence
for a long time I I just have to
speculate on why this is even in here um
I know that they reorganized the
department about six or seven years ago
so they I think they originally had four
divisions but they changed the
responsibilities of the division they
sorted them a different way and
so uh this is probably to to some people
in the department this looks like a new
responsibility for one of those
bureaus so I think that's why they
probably put it in here but I spoke to
both the state treasurer and Dena I
think her last name is call she works in
admin services and she keeps track of
the dedicated funds and she said that it
would be better not to create a new fund
but to just um alter some of the
characteristics of how that dedicated
fund is listed in the in the directory
of dedicated funds I know that that I
looked at the report that the department
files for dedicated funds and for this
one it has the RSA reference is
incorrect so that's but that's something
that can be fixed without without doing
it in this bill Dena also told me that
the department of education is up for
their fiveyear review of dedicated funds
and that that can be addressed when she
does that this summer which I think
would be a good idea because I I think
that that's this is not the only fund
that they dedicated fund that they have
that needs a little bit of fixing I mean
the funds are there and they've been
used for decades but they may want may
want to um straighten out some of the
titles that this particular one has two
different titles within the context of
that dedicated fund report and the index
it has one name and the report that's
filed by the department has slightly
different name so they can address all
of those issues that are probably
related to their
reorganization this summer all right so
you believe this this bill is
unnecessary um I I think we should
probably check with the with the
education committee but I think they
probably need the first part of it but
not the second
part so they they need to they need B
well which wouldn't be a one anymore it
could just be a b but they don't need
the part um that has to do with a new
dedicated
fund uh what about the the first part
that has processing of criminal history
record checks does that cost additional
money I think they I think they probably
need it but I would need to check we
would need to check on that to be sure
this is this section is actually you
can't tell by looking at the bill but
this is actually Ru
making so I I don't know the status of
that I do know that the issue of
criminal records check and having the
department of education do it instead of
individual school districts and saus has
been an issue for several years so my
guess is that the intent is to say the
dep the Department of Education is going
to do it but I I have not had
opportunity to verify that okay thank
you representative
PL is there anybody here who's going to
put an amendment in to the what you
think the bill should be if not what why
don't we just itl
it so so I would be willing to do an
amendment um I just need um some kind of
um understanding of the criminal records
check being in rules just to find out if
that's
needed okay but not but I would delete
the second part all right well to your
point if that technically can be in or
is in or can be in rules then then this
whole thing is not necessary uh
representative
lle I was just wondering if if when we
have a work session if we could invite a
member of the department to make sure
we're on the right track to answer
questions can yeah we can certainly try
yes represent
Aly yes
um representative
um the representative gave us uh gave me
on two possible r on dedicated fund
numbers one 123 and 321 wasn't it
or and neither of them is that 123 is
certified program fund for RSA
332e and I just went to that and it's
water treatment plant
operators so and the other one was was
is very late in the list and has already
been repealed okay so I the numbers are
one two and three and I I got the order
of them wrong but they're but they're
both those so both um Department of
Education funds and one of them is the
certification one it could be
312 and
213 well anything starting with three is
in the last few years and you said it's
been there a long time so that's another
thing
so my notes are back
here let me see uh one two three is in
acquisition no no sorry I'm
not well we can we can I guess we can
work on this later yeah we can work on
this later so I'm just I'm just coming
back from a doctor's appointment so I
you know I don't have my notes here
yet
well I guess we're not in a hurry
because we can't hear anything else
until 11:
right and it doesn't appear to be anyone
else it's quarter of
11 oh yeah we've only got 15 minutes for
this one oh I don't know I don't know if
it's not here it's not that
one
goodness 132 is a so um
facilities repr Ames I just want I just
wanted to say it's pretty obvious and
supportive representative Le please
suggestion that we need um a
knowledgeable person from the Department
of educ ation
to explain what's needed and what's not
needed um I don't
think you probably got it exactly right
representative fellows but let's let's
get it from the Department yeah
I okay does anybody have anything else I
don't have it with
me well you can if you go if you're
looking at the dedicated funds report
just search for the
word
certification yeah that one 123 is a
certification program fund but it refers
you to RSA
332e which is water
stuff now maybe the referral is
wrong to to which place it's going well
there's inconsistencies between the
index and the reports that the
department filed at the and so you think
you is it called C what's the number for
certification one uh two3 is a
certification program fund so that's the
one we're talking
about except yeah so if so the RSA RSA
it's in 612 it's referring it to this
water fund right so that may be
wrong okay well given the the
uncertainty there I think we'll I'm
assuming there's no one else to testify
there's um there's no other pin cards
and therefore I will close the public
hearing on
yeah
okay might have 1650
upat
um this is ours because it's dedicated
Farms the other ones 31 two one two
three if you when I when I put in one
two three and go three two and it's
also
hold so that
did you print it out yeah I did okay I
was rushed out without it I only meeting
at 9:30 which one was that so you search
on it and you go down to the bottom of
the report you find that one page thing
that the department submits yeah and the
RSA that it's referred to in there is at
least it's a Department of Education RSA
but it's not it's to a division it
refers to a division that is that I know
is the one that used to be where
certification was but they re redid that
whole Division and now it belongs
somewhere
else but mostly they don't they've got a
certification fund they don't need
a
I was rushing back here trying to be
here for that one and I talked I I sent
them an email last week asking them
about that bill you would think that
would trigger somebody to be here
wouldn't or at least clean it up or
both
yeah that probably
happen yeah I'll leave you
one okay the time being 1047 we will get
going on I will open the public hearing
on HB 1198 and first up I get up again
for recognize representative uh
Horgan
thank you very much Mr chair so I'm
represent Timothy Horgan from the town
of straford County the town of Durham
which is uh the entirety of straford
County District 10 which actually does
not have a state liquor store in its
Town although we do have one next door
in Lee
so this bill uh sailed through Commerce
uh without much controversy it's not
particularly complicated So currently
the state liquor the state liquor store
the state Liquor Commission can and does
keep stores open on Main routes where
traffic is busy On Any Sunday or legal
holiday with the three exceptions of
Easter Thanksgiving and Christmas and uh
the dates of Thanksgiving and Christmas
are clearly established in existing law
so uh we pretty much know when the
everybody knows when those uh those
holidays are Easter's a little bit
trickier first of all it's not actually
technically a legal holiday moves around
from year to year and actually different
religious groups observe it on different
Sundays um which I guess and the lakor
commission uses the most common date
which is observed by most Christian
denominations and this year if I
remember correctly that's March
31st um the law doesn't have any
definition of Easter and that bill makes
no attempt to deal with that um that
won't be needed if this bill becomes law
actually because there's only one other
statute that refers to Easter of course
this is the money commission it's a
straight so the main point is um there
it's enabling legislation it merely
gives a commission the option to keep
stores open on those three days the
commission is free to keep the stores
closed instead and the full-time
employees would make one and a half time
their regular pay and all the other work
rules would still apply so the this is
the money committee so the main thing is
the Liquor Commission will make more
money if HP 1198 passes so sales on
Easter Sunday um and I think this is
reflected in the fiscal note are like to
be similar to those on other March or
April Sundays historically the stores
grow sales average about a million
dollar on those Sundays with labor costs
averaging about 53,000 and that's pretty
much the only cost of keeping the store
open since they have to keep the lights
on and the air conditioning on
regardless of whether there's any
customers in the store so the potential
so that you know that's like a pretty
big uh so there's big fiscal upside to
being open on on on Easter Sunday the
potential profits from opening at
christm thanks you be Christmas are
harder to predict but but um sales
leading up to those two days are are are
robust that's what it says in the fiscal
notes so should be financially worth
worthwhile opening in those two holidays
evening sales were as little as 5.3% of
what they would be on a normal day and I
think they should be much higher than
5.3 and also this also enables the
commission to serve the public better by
getting them more opportunity to buy
wine and spirits um and mostly this
would mostly probably be people who are
traveling in need to Breck up a few
bottles of uh for responsible enjoyment
at the Holiday get togethers although
may also be useful since restaurants
some restaurants are open in that day
some Caterers happen to be um working on
that day um you know catering holiday
celebrations and that probably makes
life a little bit easier for them if
they need to uh if they discover they
have less Wier Spirits than they than
they need to serve their customers so I
think this uh I think this bill will
make a significant amount of money for
this State Liquor Commission so and this
so from the point of view of the waying
me committee's concerns um I think
there's I think this is like pretty
obviously a bill that you you should
pass and send on to the Senate so i' be
happy to take any questions if you want
thank you um before I take questions
I'll just remind the committee that this
bill and and I believe all of them that
we are hearing today are second
committee bills the policy has been
passed so whether you whether you like
this bill or not um the has been passed
previously so we are focused only on the
financial aspects of this bill and the
following bills and now represent
representative plot this is a money
question yeah um you you I understand
that there may be a revenue increase
potential yes of course but wouldn't
being open on those three holidays just
suck some revenue from other days around
the holidays um that may be the case but
in practice The Liquor Commission stays
open as many days as it can so they
they're obviously
their analysis the business seems to
indicate that they would make more sales
staying up in more days so that's uh you
know they I believe all the major sto
and this actually it says certain stores
this is actually probably most of the
stores um so they do I believe they do
mostly stay open seven days a week if
they can because they figure they'll uh
sell more more product uh if they
overall if they stay open you know rub
me every day thank you but you've read
the original fiscal note which is still
a fiscal note yes and the original
fiscal note on had says that the Liquor
Commission believes that they can lose
money by doing this I that their
expenditures are going to increase
because they're going to have to keep uh
people at time and a half there yes on
which
is on apparently more than they are
paying people for normal days except
Sundays and also that um they don't
really believe that very many people are
going to be wandering around and and
making a last minute purchase because
they've always made them in the days
before and after well I I was not
involved in writing the fiscal notes so
I can't speak too much with their
assumptions where I mean they're being
uh I think they're being cautious
because they knew last time we
introduced it it became controversial on
the other the other body that we don't
talk about but um it's
uh I think how they describe the the
labor costs um that's a relatively small
amount of what they would what they
would sell um they it's a business
decision that the Liquor Commission like
any other retailer should be free to
make for itself and in fact they stay
open on all the other legal holidays
other than Thanksgiving and Thanksgiving
and Christmas and they also uh stay open
on every Sunday aside from Easter Sunday
so I think they their analysis of
businesses is that it's uh worthwhile
keeping the stores open as many days as
possible even if that does mean labor
costs which I think are not uh not
really not really huge part of their
business their main cost is actually
just the cost of maintaining the stores
and also like the cost of buying the
product not so much the salaries that
the liquor store clerks make when the
stores open so that's that's my belie
follow up thank
you on did The Liquor Commission come to
the
hearing to recall that I seem to recall
that they uh they did to the Commerce
Committee hearing so they
um um you can uh that would probably be
reflected in the bill file which I don't
have a copy of and
um I'm not sure if there's anybody here
to speak to it but um they they they did
they did they did come to and they were
I think not they certainly did not try
to dissuade me or also uh
there there are other members of the uh
committee this is a this is a identical
the bill that was passed in the previous
session as amended by the Commerce
Committee so
um representative fellows followed by
representative PL yes and so one of the
concerns is is what would overtime cost
because the employees that would be in
the store would be working
overtime I these are the regular sea
employ um
Union people that would be impacted by
this it's this is something that would
have to be addressed in the labor
contract yes so so I'm I'm wondering if
they used um time and a
half for for work on a Sunday but I
think that it's possible either they
have or it could be negotiated if
they're going to work on a holiday and
it's one of these major holidays that
they may be entitled to more than that
they get time in a half for overtime but
they're also on it's on a major holiday
and that could cost even
more so was did you hear any discussions
about that
issue that was not discussed I will
point to the fact on other legal
holidays The Liquor Commission has made
a business decision to keep most of the
larger stores open so they
they uh they must believe the additional
labor cost offsets uh offsets the uh is
is is is more than sufficient the
revenues from having the clerks in the
store are uh more than sufficient to be
justify having the clerks there
obviously this is an issue that has to
be discussed in the labor contract and
they do have a strong union I mean it's
a fair it's I think it's generally
considered a good place to work but they
do have a strong union they'll discuss
this is merely in enabling legislation
which enables The Liquor Commission to
you know suggest having the stores open
those two days that I can't speak to
whether whether what would happen in the
uh any contract negotiations between the
uh Liquor Commission and the sea
but representative
plat yes uh to counter the question I
made earlier uh this this only the the
law say is if this passes
May the commission may in its discretion
open those days so I suppose if this
passes The Liquor Commission could try a
few stores see what the revenue impact
is see if the revenue impact is higher
than what they lose the previous days
and if it's worth it keep it doing it
not they don't have to right exactly so
it's it's up to them to make the bus
business decision and I'm sure they'll
I'm sure they'll uh give it I'm sure
they won't I'm sure they'll like look at
the data if if they do start opening
stores on those three days they'll look
at the data from to see if it's
worthwhile to do it the next year or not
so thank you representative Bolton uh
thank you Mr chair so uh this has
happened in the past where um
representative PL has spoken or address
the question that I would like to do so
um but how many stores I I thought maybe
if this was like a liquor commission's
policy that all stores would have to
honor you know opening on on all the
holidays if if if we go in that
direction I didn't think stores had that
discretion well I can't guess I'm not an
expert exactly how the State Liquor
Commission organizes its stores I mean
they're um they're all so that that I
can't argue exactly but do know they
they are opening more stores and keeping
them open they seem to be keeping them
open as long as you know they can keep
them staffed so they're they um so they
they do seem to be making decision to
have more stores newer stores larger
stores and uh to have to you know keep
them sufficiently staffed so I don't
think they're they're not uh I don't
think they're closing stores because of
the labor cost per se so I think they're
they're in an expansion mode so
I I don't I'm not necessarily the best
person to answer that question so uh
representative Oris did you have a
question yes thank you Mr
chair thank you representative Horgan
for being
here I am uh let's see Representatives
Platt and Bolton have already taken the
Thunder out of what I wanted to
ask so uh what I what I was wondering is
if uh do you think selling additional
spirits and spiritual holidays would
enhance the
spirits you don't have to answer that no
I don't have an answer for
that we could have a spirit of debate
about
that
all right representative
fellows so one of the things I see when
I read this it says like right now
full-time employees are not obligated to
work on Sunday or these three holidays
it's by it's you know voluntary if they
want to work on Sundays but you by
Crossing out um you know
this how you how you're amending the
bill you're saying that they they're not
obligated to work on Sundays but they
would be obligated to work on Easter and
Thanksgiving and
Christmas because you're Crossing out
those
words correct well I think we're just uh
the way I interpret it um the way I
interpret this this has like
uh it this has this B has passed the
house before it came halfway passing the
other body but I think what that means
is just places those three days on the
same um so places Easter Sunday um on
the same and the same so the law that
appli to all the other 51 Sundays of the
year would apply to Easter Sunday and
then the law that applies on on the
other legal holidays uh would also apply
to those two holiday so I don't think it
changes uh so I think those um so I
don't think it changes anything in the
law or the labor contract necessarily uh
B beyond what already exists for all the
other holidays and all the other days
so rep representative elberger thank you
Mr chairman um just comment on
representative fellow's statement
following the stricken language there is
a sentence that says although full-time
employees shall be given the option of
working no such employee shall be
required to work on such days so
employees will not be forced to work on
those
days I'm
I'm
assuming that the Liquor Commission
which seems to be doing a pretty good
job of
managing the finances of the
commission uh unless they have any
serious objection to this and I I I'm
not noticing any yet at least then there
shouldn't from my perspective there
shouldn't be a re any reason to turn
this down as it is simply enabling
legislation it is not a
requirement representative sodi thank
you uh do you have any information from
other states that are open on these
holidays uh how much money they're
bringing in on those dates um well
frankly no we're one of the few states
that has State uh state liquor stores of
course I mean well I mean but on the
private uh businesses that would be open
on those States um I haven't contact any
private businesses I mean I have noticed
anecdotally that liquor stores well our
neighboring state of Massachusetts has
all private Liquor Stores um and they
most of them do stay open on Sunday I
don't believe they used to have Blue
laws in Massachusetts but they don't but
I think most of those two stay open as
many days as they can just like the
State Liquor Commission U has been in
the practice of
doing okay thank you very
much is there anyone else who would like
to testify on HB 1198
saying none I'll close the public
hearing on HB
1198 okay I'll now open the public
and I'll uh recognize representative
toet thank you Mr chair
uh I'd like to offer house build
FN to the
committee and doesn't appear there's a
fiscal note specific
so Mr chairman the last
yes represent elme on I at least am in
possession of the fiscal note that was
put up on
22924 which says the legislative budget
assistant states that this bill is
amended by the house has no fiscal
impact on any state county and local
expenditures or revenue and I also
scanned through it and it's about a
commission at this point I think
um but no it's it's just um agricultural
definitions and there is no dedicated
fund uh the um on the last page um of
the fiscal note here it says decrease of
Z to
$127,000 and that is the old fiscal
that's the old fiscal note okay the old
one yeah we she just handed we just uh
did she hand those out too received uh
the fisal note that's amended
22924 I didn't get that oh but oh it may
be in these yeah it just came oh oh well
then it's not in those
things
it's I got it off the internet two days
ago no it's Ava I picked it up
oh okay yes that is something that we
received this morning it says the office
of legislative budget assistant States
this bill as amended by the house has no
fiscal impact on the state county or
local expenditures on Revenue right that
simplifies things greatly
yes so we have half an hour wow that you
just can't tell sometimes all right um
well I'm going to close the public
hearing on HB
1293 the next the next hearing doesn't
start until 11:30 the other one that is
like this is
1709 by the way that is correct 1709
that's going to that's scheduled for
12:15 uh that has no longer has a fiscal
note yeah it's too bad it was it's too
bad I don't have the order reversed
there I
know Mr
chairman yes just to mention on 1709 I
do have an amendment for technical
correction because the effective date
was omitted so I'll pass that out now
okay thank
you
interesting there is an effective dat on
it
yeah
oh
okay all right this this is actually the
handout is actually for hp1
1565 oh this she'll take effects that's
great takes
effect iose she might imp if that's a
fun passage
but I think it be 63
days and for
1565 we all got handed out a new fiscal
note as
well
and we also got a new one for
oh oh no we didn't this is is Horgan's
testimony uh we got a new one for
1611 which looks like it may not have a
fiscal
impact that's the one after the forest's
carbon but it is a little
confusing the fiscal
note
f
e
Michael it doesn't look like we have
anyone here to introduce the
bill
um maybe he can well no he's not you
have to be a state
yes no you need to go to the front well
would someone like to all right
representative duet's going to do
it
thank you Mr chairman I'd like to
introduce House Bill
FN for the committee's
consideration thank
you representative ery
Mr chair I had asked um um Mr Lambert
Over in legislative research to give us
some background on this I forward it to
you you may wish to forward it to the
committee uh or not it's up to you but
primarily what this is is the probate
judge
said that this should be uh on
legislative action because the state was
involved and Rich did some further
research and came up and said that
historically the uh General Court
handled intestate uh decisions regarding
the disposition of funds this is merely
a disposition of fund it doesn't do
anything other than give money to where
the guy wanted it to go and which
includes the state so okay thank you I
do have uh another pink card here um
Michael Haley from New Hampshire
doj
uh thank you Mr chair um the committee
staff asked our office to attend this
hearing just to provide any background
that's necessary I have some written
explanation because our office was
involved in the underlying matter um so
uh our office I'm Michael Haley the
assist or the um acting director of
charitable trusts at the Department of
Justice our office is involved in um in
Probate Estates that have charitable
bequests um this particular estate um Mr
teest Bano died without a will so it was
unusual for us to be involved in this um
however the the administrator of his
estate was his good friend and wanted to
um have the the proceeds of his estate
go to a a charitable purpose um and the
judge asked us to become involved to
determine if there was a way to achieve
that through the probate process um we
reviewed it and found that um RSA
5611 provides that if someone dies in
tested without any living family within
the fourth degree that the money goes to
the state um and so in order to uh have
that money be directed to a particular
purpose the legislature would need to be
the the body that made that decision um
so that the judge entered an order to
that effect um and I understand that the
executive or the administrator of his
will worked with the representative to
draft this bill and this is the result
of those efforts so I'm available if
there are any questions about that
underlying proceeding but our office is
not taking a position on this
legislation thank you and uh those some
of those comments are in line with
representative uh what representative
Ellery had found out from uh Mr Lambert
so that's good to hear does anyone have
any questions representative fellows I I
just have a te technical um question
about the process because this is not
amending any RSA which is what we
usually see for builds so is this called
a chapter law and like how do how is it
recorded in record because we're going
to vote on it um that's a little bit
outside of my area of expertise I
understand this to essentially be an
appropriation that money has come into
the estate from Mr bhanu's estate he had
about
$131,000 I believe when he passed and so
this is simply appropriating that money
to a particular purpose in this case
with the DHHS um Refugee and
resettlement
office thank
you
okay seeing no more questions thank you
thank you very much Mr
chair Mr chairman I do have a question
for yes Mr Mr Haley yeah I guess we do
have one more
questiones reading the Dr
methodology will money from
this uh uh settlement will the doj be
paid from that money's coming to
administer this uh so our office is not
receiving any money we're not in uh we
wouldn't be receiving anything the the
money would go from his estate so the
the executive would cut a check to the
treasury um it would go into General
funds and this is appropriating out of
General funds to the DHHS
office
okay now I think we're done thank
you is there anyone else who would like
to testify on
hb303 seeing none I will close the
public hearing on
hb303 we now have about eight minutes
until the next hearing
good so that representative PL can
finish
right what is
this those done
yeah
17 we don't have anyone to introduce the
bill
again okay the time being 1147 I'm going
to open the public hearing on hb1
1517 and it doesn't uh do I I don't
doesn't look like I have anyone to
introduce the bill uh
again I will represent just said it's
already going up
there good afternoon Mr chairman again
uh I'd like to offer for consideration
of the committee h b 15 17
FN okay I do have some other pink cards
um I have uh Bruce knur and uh Keem mang
Wang from New Hampshire Dr have you both
come up at the same
time
for
good morning my name is Keen M Wong tax
policy council with the New Hampshire
Department of Revenue and my name is
Bruce canu I'm the municipal supervisor
at the Department of
Revenue uh the department does not take
a position on this bill right now uh
what's coming around to you is the
fiscal noqu guide uh which is the um
quick gu of the fiscal note that was
prepared by the department when it was
first
introduced
so I I'll not read through the uh the
fiscal no quick guy but essentially
um the uh what the department has read
the bill uh trying to accomplish is to
take uh any excess monies from the games
of chance in excess of the $6.6 million
and use that excess money to uh to
reduce the uh the swept calculation of
the $363
million uh upon um reviewing this bill
the department found that there are
certain areas uh that might be of
concern um that might potentially help
improve um the
bill uh first thing is that the bill
does not clearly stipulate the uh the
date range of the uh of the payments
that was deposit that that would be
deposited into the uh education trust
fund um and so the department being
having
to uh create or or calculate uh the tax
rate to arrive at the $363 million uh
will need uh specific information as to
uh what amount will be in excess of the
$6.6 million and um how that amount
would be um will be calculated so would
that information be coming directly from
Treasury or would that be a a
calculation that was to be done by the
department so that's not clear on the
bill itself uh it would be definitely be
beneficial to the department if uh if
that is made clear uh if this bill is to
pass uh and if this uh if that
information was to come from from
another party let's say from from
treasury uh the department would request
that maybe a uh a timeline be provided
in the bill to State when the
information will be provided to us to
perform the calculation uh that the
preferred date would be uh early
September hopefully maybe by September 1
um so that we can start um preparing the
calculation and we'll be happy to take
any
questions represented
fellows thank you Mr chair
um so the
Dr needs to know at at some year in the
future if we pass this bill Dr needs to
know how much to reduce the
swep um warrant
by and so so the question one question
is when is that
known and my guess
is you the Department of Education would
probably have to tell you that and
they'd have to be tell telling you that
for what
happened the year
before is that you're not how you see it
um I I I was thinking that probably the
information would come from treasury as
opposed to Department of Education but
I'm not I'm not certain because it's
talking about the deposits into the game
um there's a specific fund for the game
of chance um and I believe that would be
information will come from
treasury representative PL I'm having
trouble understanding let's say it was
6.6 million consistently you knew that
this would Reduce swep by 6.6 million so
it would not okay what would it do uh no
according to the language of the bill it
will be reducing the 363 Million by
anything in excess of the $6.6
million given that let's say there is is
an excess of say a million so it reduces
swept by a million that reduces the
revenue from swept uh does it also
reduce the amounts going back to the
towns and cities as a result of that
reduction in
Revenue uh yes I believe yes that's
correct
yeah R El me um did you try to find out
what the on
amount that has been coming out of game
these games of Champs there it's a
narrow SE sector on has looked like for
the last 10 years
say or you're just assuming that it's
going to grow yeah I I we did not look
through the history of the uh of the
game of chain Revenue I believe uh
through well I believe reading the bill
I think the 6.6 million was the either
the budgeted amount or was the last the
last um fiscal Year's amount of the of
the uh revenue from Game of CH I'm I'm
not sure if um
if I I don't know what uh what was done
in the past uh in developing this bill
whether fortunately we do have have
Lottery behind you
oh okay uh yes represent
elberger thank you Mr chair thanks for
taking my question there may actually be
two
where this 6.6
million whose pocket is it going to be
coming out of is it going to be coming
out of the owners is it going to be
coming out of the gambling Commission
because there's a pot of money there'll
be $6.6 million less under this proposal
who's not getting
it
I I don't believe that there is a
transfer of money from the uh of the
excess of $6.6
million I believe it's just an
accounting to
reduce the um the 363 Million by the
number in exess of 6.6 I I don't believe
there's any kind of transfer from one
from One Fund to another fund Mr
chairman follow yes
follow I'm I'm trying
to the amount going into swep with be
reduced by this amount which be would be
coming out of games of
chance
correct uh that's
that's I don't believe I can answer that
question um according to the bill it
doesn't say that the money will be
coming out of the games of chance it
just says that the amount that's an
excess of $6.6 million is used to reduce
the um the 363 million
calculation okay I may need to ask
someone else this question thank you Mr
chairman yes billsburg so isn't it the
case that all of the uh uh funds from
the Lottery Commission currently go into
the education trust fund so isn't this
isn't the education trust fund the
answer to the question so because
this takes anything in excess of 6.6
million that's a credit against the
amount to be collected from the
municipalities through the property tax
it's a wash yes sir the the bill the
bill I think states that it's still
going those revenues to the education
trust fund it's the excess above 6.6
million that is a number that is coming
to Dr so that we can raise instead of
363 million in that example of a million
excess so by a number you mean it's an
accounting adjustment as Kean had
suggested it's not an actual transfer of
funds right right okay that's how I
understood it
too okay any other
questions seeing none no represent
fellows um yes I'm trying to think about
when you look at the um education trust
fund as a
whole
how would this money be specifically
identified on a separate line I'm just
thinking a lot of things a lot of
different programs are funded out of the
education trust
fund
and this is kind of a it's kind of
saying a little slice of what's going
into the education fund will be used for
this one very
specific um you know
use and if somehow that needs to be
identified within the
fund representative fellows I
would from our perspective in Municipal
we're looking for that accounting number
so that the next swept warrant or
warrants in total would raise in this
hypothetical $1 million less
proportioned out to all the the
municipalities
it's Gaming revenue that's going to be
in the education trust fund at least as
I would understand it but it's not going
to be a million dollars raised through
the
swept tax the property
tax so what happens to the monies in the
education trust
fund coming in from The Gaming
revenue is then uh
well it's you know it's not dr's Affair
you were right it would be education and
the law dictating how those funds are
then um appropriated out and so forth
but this looks to me like a just a
change from a million dollars on swept
to a million dollars into the education
trust
fund from RE U The Gaming
revenue but but again it's Mechanics for
the municipal Bureau and really our
interest was in the timing of the of
that piece of data and and the amount
and the determination in the statute as
to who is going to create that
calculation representative
ducet thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question so if I'm
understanding this
correctly I would assume the intent of
of this bill would would be to lessen
the tax burden on the taxpayer down
Downstream but what I'm hearing in the
testimony is if it's if the dollars
aren't in the education trust
fund they and they go to swept it it's
kind of a wash uh accounting wise if if
you have those funds there it's not
going to affect the the swep
rate I mean does doeses this piece of
legislation have The Wanted
effect I mean the legislative intent I'm
reading into it a little bit but it's
it's kind of murky here uh thank you for
the question representative um I I don't
think we are in the position to talk
about the intent of the the bill that
might be the uh the sponsor might be
able to be more Geared for that um but
this is how we've interpreted the uh the
bill and and how it's going to
work follow okay let let me make that
assumption okay and I'm asking you will
that if my intent is to lower the
property tax of a property owner uh
swept end of things shifting these
dollars from one from the Statewide uh
from the education trust fund to swept
is it going to have my intended effect
in your in your
opinion again sir I'm not entire L
certain what the intent might have been
but I believe that I can say this if Dr
is told that there is a million dollars
of Gaming
revenue in excess of the 6.6
million will'll set the the warrant to
raise
$362 million and if you're paying that
property tax all of it I know this a Hy
pathetical you're going to pay less on
the your swept tax on your tax bill
representative PL what happens now to uh
any excesses in the uh education trust
fund does it accumulate it does it off
what happens to
it representative PL I I don't know I'm
not qualified to answer that question
about the funds that at the state level
on the on the education trust fund all
right I'm going to let representative
omy answer it
thank you on if there is a surplus left
at the end of the year the finance
committee can kidnap it for the general
fund or send it on and if they do then
it goes to the rainy day fund
probably thank you representative
Ames this isn't really a question uh
well I'll I'll start with this um if you
with your $1 million
hypothesis so then you're working with
362 million instead of
363 and you then uh apply your
calculator to the situation and
distribute the money um well before you
do that you somewhere in there you
determine a Statewide rate right right
an equalized rate and um right now it's
somewhere about
1.12 or 1.10 something like that anyway
it's very
low um and when I you go down and you
take $1 million and try to spread it out
across all our
communities it's
uh it's not going to be very visible is
that it's going to be a small amount of
money except for the the biggest places
like Manchester they might it might be
visible there am I correct in saying
that representative Ames I I I'm not
sure how to answer that question um is
it visible would be if you compared um
the last
363 apportionment to
362 um it filters down starts out with
the dollars raised in each municipality
and that in turn is as you know a
portion down to every single taxpayer so
um but 1 million over 363 million I'm
not sure what percent that is but yeah
it
is Ron
elberger being the non-math genius here
um what I'm getting from this is that
the difference is
1.8% in ter if you divide 363
million
if you go the other way six it turns out
to be under
2% in terms of the impact on the whole
on the Statewide education trust fund so
the impact on a tax bill is going to
be no it will be visible but I'm not
sure
noticeable represent plat ta it's 0. 2%
1 ided 363 is
.002 which is 2%
227% so fairly negligible representative
fellows um so let's talk another
hypothetical I I know it's never going
to happen but suppose the amount of
money raised from the these games of
chance was turned out to be
$370
million then there'd be no Statewide
property tax
correct so it's 370 million in excess of
$6.6
million yeah so according to the the
Lang according to the language of the
bill you'll need the 363 minus whatever
access if the access is 370 yeah I would
think that that is the
answer okay thank you very much thank
you I have no more pin cards um is there
anyone else like to testify on hb1
1517 representative Aly I would like to
see on the lottery tell us how much uh
is actually coming in for these games of
chance they're severely limited in the
definitions to the traditional games of
chance before anything changed
okay and we don't tax them
much
good afternoon Mr chairman members of
the committee uh Charlie
McIntyre um and Valerie King from the
lottery hey questions um so from FY 23
the games of chance Revenue after
operating expenses was approximately $
5.38 million that was the highest year
which had been realized in those
revenues and that was due to the
increased bet
limit represent fellows yes could thank
you could you please tell us
specifically um which activities are
within um
287 ddon
20 so that that refers to the taxes on
the different games a 3% tax on your
tournament poker games and a 10% tax on
all the other games of chance so
followup games of chance right so I need
so that's tell me what it's not it's not
it's not sports betting no it's not the
video games no right it's just the it's
roulette it's cash poker games it's um
um
Blackjack
okay represent
Ames just to make sure I understood you
said
million in fiscal year 23 yes was the
gross was the was the revenue that you
received uh 5.66 4 and our expenses were
$283,000 which the statute says you are
subtracted out yes and then that's the
money that was sent to the education
trust fund correct that would be the
portion of our transfer so approximately
$400,000 a month give or take and is
that was that a very low year or was
that a typical year there was the that
was the highest year of games or chance
Revenue we've realized and that was
because of the legislatively approved
increase bet limit so under under this
bill um if you subtract $6 million from
5.3 you're
negative you get the
point yes okay that that was very
helpful represent
ol just as a hypothetical up in Milton
somebody won was was 39 million or
something like that uh 13.9 million 13
there was a three and a nine in there I
had all the
numbers the uh the question is will that
increase substantially to the point that
we reach the threshold with one big
winner no so the mega buuck it's a mega
buuck win it's a traditional Lottery
product it's not under 287 it's under
284 thank you thank you very
much okay I'm going to close the public
hearing on HB
I'm going to open the hearing on hp1
see I have no pink cards do I have
someone to introduce they're coming
okay well I don't know we
might
157 well
1517 in there this this is all
um and I'll recognize representative
ducet to introduce hb5 afternoon again
Mr chairman I'd like to introduce House
Bill
1565 FN for the committee's
consideration thank you
I have a pink card from
um Colleen Smith from New Hampshire
DHHS okay and we did representative Aly
just uh reminded me we have a new fiscal
note on
1565 that got passed
around
if I have
it ter Terry's
yes all
right okay yeah we have we have two
handouts we have uh the fiscal node on
hb1 1565 and uh represent spilsbury's
change of
date
okay thank you you
can good afternoon members of the
committee thank you for allowing me to
speak on House Bill 1565 my name is
Colleen Smith I'm the administrator for
the Department of Health and Human
Services food protection section and I'm
happy to answer any questions regarding
the fiscal note we did provide an
amended fiscal note due to the bill
Amendment to the LBA last night so if
you um have any questions be happy to
answer those
represent
elme thank you the fiscal
note says that um the amended bill which
got rid of a bunch of other stuff
um on is going to reduce your revenues
by
10,000 a
year
and possibly increase your expenditures
by 10,000 a year so those are just
estimates the bill as amended would
allow producers of acidified foods to do
so without a food license so right now
they have to if they want to produce
these products in a commercial kitchen
they pay a $350 annual fee so we are not
sure how many would opt not to pursue
that license they still could produ to
this license should this bill pass but
we uh it's we had listed that as an
estimate and indeterminable cuz we're
not sure how many of those would
actually opt out of not needing that
license from
us and as far as expenditures um due to
um this being a higher risk food that
would be allowed to be made in a Home
Food Kitchen we could project that there
might be more increases of foodborn
illness that the department would have
to investigate and that is why we had
estimated there might be some additional
expenditures due due to that
work
represent fellows can you just tell us
some examples of what are what are the
foods that would not need the licensed
kitchen anymore so this would allow
acidified foods to be made in a home
kitchen without a license an example of
that would be pickles or
salsa any other
questions represent a PL would it
include tomato products as well
tomato products it could um us usually
um acidified Foods could be tomato
products like a a hot sauce that that
contains mostly tomato
products okay yes repres
bely sorry I'm just trying to get a
broader idea of what acidified foods are
um so would this include like kombucha
or yogurt or like kefir so these
wouldn't be fermented products like
those these would be Foods where you're
adding acid to bring the the natural PH
down okay thank
you represent fellows thank you I'm I'm
wondering like especially when you
mentioned Tomatoes like canned
tomatoes uh will will it be necessary
for um your agency to do more INSP
inpections of these products when you
find them in a in a I don't know
wherever you wherever you check them
because you know right now you know that
they should have had a license to
produce them but now they might be um
that's actually a policy question well
I'm I'm asking no because I'm Excuse me
I'm thinking in terms of more
inspections or more time to make
inspections because these prodcts will
need a closer look no would that
impact the
um so so actually the because these
products would be exempt from our
license and inspection they there
wouldn't be an anticipated cost due to
increase
inspection okay thank you very
much I'm going to close the public
hearing on
HB 1565
um I forgot to ask if anyone else wants
to testify on hb1
1565 okay thank
you
am oh
yeah uh representative spillsbury did
you want to speak on the amendment I
very quickly could it be simpler uh
chairman Aaron of uh agriculture
environment uh simply pointed out that
in the course of amending the bill in
their committee they had inadvertently
left out the 60-day effective dates so
she asked me to do the favor of having
this amendment prepared
non-controversial thank you thank
you
oh
okay there you
go
1709 okay I'm going to open the public
her on HP
1709 and recognize representative
Kelly
thank you Mr chair um I'm recovering
from a little cold so I'll keep my mask
on I'll try to speak loud and clearly
but if for any reason you need to hear
me just let me know um so I I passed
around I don't sure wasn't sure if you
had already received it um in your
packet but I passed along the amended um
fiscal note uh as we amended in the
house two weeks ago this bill no longer
has any fiscal impact um I want to make
sure you saw that before I presented it
um but if I have any questions on the
bill or anything I can answer please let
me know thank you that um yes the just
to highlight that again there is no
fiscal note on this um this this bill
technically could have been waved and
not even come to this committee so um
but with that if anyone has any
questions
um I don't see any questions so thank
you very
much I'm going to close the public
hearing on HB
1709 yes represent er uh considering
that the seals with the forest maybe we
should take a trip up and see what a
forest looks
like Mr chair I can't tell the forest
from the trees well then okay then I
guess the Trip's not
necessary all right we have we have one
bill left um but uh we can't start for
another nine
minutes take the children to the
forest there's a
German children story about kids in
forest and gingerbread and ovens
and Mr chair yes i' just like to
apologize for interrupting you what I
was trying to ask is it what I was
thinking is that they would need to test
those products to see if they really
were acidified to whatever level of acid
you know would qualify as acidified
that's what I was thinking they might
need more inspectors or take longer to
do inspectors inspections thank
you 29 oh I
see she
left
and
one I'm going to open the public hearing
on hb1
1611 and um invite up representative uh
wellner thank you CH chairman CH janigan
and members of the Ways and Means
Committee I guess and congratulations
are in in place for the chair chairman
who's now taken over this position thank
you
um so this bill actually if you look at
the bill you'll see it says it was the
first committee was Health and Human
Services and it got um
sent instead to the special child care
committee and I'm on that committee so
and I'm also one of the co-sponsors and
Rebecca McWilliams who is the Prime
sponsor of this bill couldn't be with us
today so I will just um briefly tell you
what happened at the special child care
committee we did um do a couple of um
fairly minor amendments to the bill one
of them maybe Isn't So minor the way the
bill was originally written was that
this special child care fund could be
used to um make direct payments to
childcare employees
ye uh for things like the cost of health
insurance the cost of
um benef benefit type things that they
might they might um
need what we did in the
um special committee was we amended it
to have these um grants going to the
employer and then the employer would
work with the employees in um providing
incentives for the employees the um
major issue behind the bill is to retain
our child care
Workforce um I'm sure all of you have
probably seen articles heard news
reports that the child care Workforce is
um in in really in Desperate shape um
we've we've lost many many employees in
that in that area and it's so important
because without the child care Workforce
you can't have people working in other
businesses that um are so important to
this committee because you're the Ways
and Means Committee and you're looking
for businesses in New Hampshire to um
pay their pay their um business
taxes um then the only and the only
other I I think small amendment that we
added was that the Department of Health
and Human Services would um develop the
rules around this fund there is
no
appropriation into this fund at this
time this is basically a fund being set
up in
anticipation that in the future there
will be funds available for Workforce in
the last budget in House Bill 2 there
was a $15 million appropriation made to
the childcare
Workforce and if this Bill had been in
place it would have gone into that
fund um it would go into this fund so in
anticipation that in the future there
will be um funds available for the child
care Workforce this just sets up a fund
for how those would be distributed um
there's a lot of talk about the
childcare Workforce at both the state
and federal level um anticipating that
there will be more funds available to
retain and um and encourage people to go
into the child care um in making Child
Care career so
um I will just close there and maybe you
have questions about
it representative PL I read the bill
represent walner and I didn't see
non-aps anywhere so it is a lapsing fund
no dedicated No it should be it should
be a non-aps
fund representative
Aly okay
right yes representative
leapley thank you Mr chair uh thank you
representative wner for taking my
question um in your work on the
commission did you come across existent
federal grants that are available for
this or is this something we're hoping
for in the future I think this is just
something no I did not come across any
specific Federal money at this point but
there is so much talk about the child
care Workforce and what's happening not
just in New Hampshire but Nationwide it
is a very low wage profession and and
we're having a really hard time
recruiting people to go into this
Workforce and then once we get them
there retaining them um so we need to
find some ways to encourage people to
come to this
Workforce follow up please um the other
question I had is um line 27 and line 30
talks about child care tuition
assistance
um my understanding of that is if a
parent were working in child care that
it would help pay for their child care
somewhere else um my question is I it
does say job related education
expenses um I'm
wondering how that's characterized if uh
if a child care worker were working on a
degree a ba
or associates degree um how would that
be is what would job related mean job
related I think would mean um there are
certain requirements in licensing for
what you need um in order to be a child
care provider um and then ongoing you
have to have so many hours every year of
training so I think those job related
expenses around that would be would be
covered as people try to move up a
career ladder and maybe go from having
just a few college credits in child
development maybe they move on to an
associates degree um I think that's
where we really would look to the
department to in the promation of rules
around how that would be
handled thank
you representa El
me thank you
um
this on what is this eligible individual
employee because
you've Empower owered an eligible
individual employee whose employer
didn't want to join the program to
get on a health saving
account insurance all sorts of
things
so this actually and I'm sorry I forgot
that this one this actually came up at
the um special child care committee that
part was not in the original Bill and
there was some concern among the members
of the committee that since we uh we're
going to make these um contributions
directly to the employe
employer there might be some employers
for whatever reason that might not want
to do
this maybe they didn't feel they had the
administrative bandwidth to do it
whatever their reason might be they
would not do that do it so in order to
be sure that this would be available to
anyone working in the child care field
not just those who's their employer
chose to do this um that paragraph was
added so that it means that that if I
worked in a trial care facility that
didn't participate in this program as a
child care professional I could Prof I
could apply on my own and I think that
that's another place where we would have
to promate some rules follow up follow
up on I think it's more than rules
because on
this individual
employee has to go straight to the
department and the department is saying
they aren't going to have a
cost because it's all going to be put
off on this uh entity that they pick to
do the
work I'm sorry I'm just I guess I'm not
following the question on well we have
a representative
Ames I don't think the fiscal note says
that the department will
not um incur costs in relationship to
processing an employee it says that the
costs are indeterminable because they
don't know right uh the number of
employers who won't participate right
right thank you
anybody else representative uh shamberg
yes thank you for taking my question
representative uh you mentioned on
line uh
15 uh grants shall be awarded and then
you me mentioned flexible funding on
line
16 for informational purposes what do
you see the
total Grant uh cost to be for a for an
employer
uh what is the cost for child care
overall the cost for child care overall
o i mean the whole universe of child
care
um in New Hampshire and I think that we
actually have people and that are going
to speak after me that can really
probably give you that information
better than I can but in New Hampshire I
I think the what famili is what it's
costing for um a preschool child in a
child care center probably averages
about
$115,000 a
year
babies obviously cost more because the
um CH staff child ratio is much
different you have to have one staff
member for every four
babies um for a four-year-old you need
one staff member for every thing it's
every 10 or 12 children so there there's
a little bit different cost depending on
the age of the child but it's very
expensive represent
elme thank you
on is there any indication of What
entity
could would take this
on
and would it only happen if they found a
pocket of money to do
it I I think there are um groups that
would be capable of taking on a project
like this and
um you know I don't I couldn't
specifically say who they are but um I
think that there would be would be um
groups that would be able to handle this
kind of a this kind of a program
um I'll get you a minute I just want to
let the committee know I have um six uh
more pink cards of from those who want
to testify and um well I I've got one
more question that actually I think the
representative should be able to answer
uh which is you there was 15 million
that was put in the budget for child
care do you know how it was spent and
who spent it yes it it was um
appropriated to Health and Human
Services it was $1 15 million for the
workforce um the Department of Health
and Human Services has not um finalized
the grants at this point um I believe I
don't know whether the department is
going to to uh speak today or not but
they could probably give you a lot more
information about how they we they are
in the process but it was a $15 million
appropriation for the
banum so they have time to to get those
those grants out to the
employers followup follow up is that
lapsing no I don't believe it is a
lapsing
fund thank
you okay seeing no more questions thank
you very much
next I have um well and let me just say
I've got six pink cards here I think
everyone is aware that this policy has
passed so we don't need to talk about
policy so much I think we understand the
need um so our our our Charter here is
to focus on on the cost um next I'm
going to call up uh will
Stewart
please turn on your
microphone thank you good perfect sorry
about that thank you Mr chairman members
of the committee for the record my name
is Will Stewart and I'm the executive
director of stay work play New Hampshire
which is a Statewide nonprofit whose
mission is to attract and retain more
young people here in the granite state
which is the second oldest state in the
country and certainly don't want to go
over all the reasons reasons you know
why this is a good idea policy-wise as
you mentioned this has been um decided
in that regard you know that said I do
want to say that you know I think this
is you know one of the smartest
Investments the state can make uh at
State workor play we've been going all
around the state you these past couple
of months last week we were in the Mount
Washington Valley in The Lakes Region
tonight we're going to be in do we are
hearing about child care everywhere we
go uh the expense you know that it uh
poses to young families and people who
want to start young families if they can
even find it um so I won't um you know
Rumer too many more of the reasons just
want to express our full support for
this bill and its funding thank you
thank you any questions representative
shamberg uh one question thank you for
taking my question is cost different in
different parts of their state here for
child care I would leave that uh
specific question to some of the experts
behind me but uh that certainly seems to
be the case anecdotally that I hear but
it's expensive no matter where it seems
to be based on the wages that people
make in different parts of the state as
well any other
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank
you next I
have um Jackie
Cowell good afternoon how do you do my
name is Jackie Cowell I'm the executive
director of early learning New Hampshire
we are a Statewide nonprofit uh working
around Child Care issues here in our
state and so um if I may ask a question
chairman sure um so I we do have a few
people here who've traveled far who just
very briefly want to talk about the
policy they're not experts in the
finance of this or the the cost of this
would it be okay if they just took a
minute or so they they they they're
they're here part of those pink cards
sometimes for the first time and they
wouldn't be able to answer the question
about the financing would it be okay if
they still spoke um sure thank you
appreciate that and um so I I know the
department is here as well to talk about
what they feel is the fiscal impact for
them the way this was drafted and we we
really talked with this is a bipartisan
bill as you know um it was a originally
bipartisan bill that passed unan
unanimously as you know out of the house
special committee on a bipartisan basis
as well and so was really clear that
this was the year to establish the fund
get it ready as representative walner
said perhaps there might be some federal
funding coming within the next year
before the next banian budget is passed
and so it would be up and running and
ready to receive those funds and again
it would be understood that there is an
administrative piece to any federal
funds that come that DHHS can use to
administer also as we mentioned with the
entity The Entity with a contract with
bhhs would be able to take whatever um
funding is passed next year during the
budget cycle if any the legislature
would have its determination when we
were talking with Senator Bradley for
instance and Senator Innis and a few
others they were very clear this is the
year to set the fund up to that
infrastructure and next year if possible
to bring in some um possibilities of
some fun of funding for that fund so my
hope is again next year when that
funding is um determined but it would be
there would be a piece of that funding
that would automatically go to the
administration it wouldn't be an extra
cost that would be my thought thank you
thank you any
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank
you uh next I have a pin card for
Samantha
Maderos hopefully I said that
correctly you got it um I will be very
brief because um my testimony was mostly
focused on policy so I I really do thank
you for your time to um hear my story I
come from Midstate Health Center we run
a child care center that is located in
Plymouth New Hampshire so we have just
over 60 children and I just want to
share this brief story that's just
really showcasing why this is so so
important um recently one of our infant
room teachers has left us she's locating
um relocating down South for a better um
paying career not in child care um this
has caused us to have to prepare some of
our families to cut our infant room
attendance in half so that's really
impacting not just the center's finances
to stay open and and pay the rest for
staff but also these families who are
relying on us for child care um we've
struggled immensely to find replacement
as you know uh recruiting is challenging
but retaining the staff that we can get
is extremely important so wage increases
um PTO health insurance all of these
things are so critically important to um
make sure that those staff we can get on
are are staying with us and taking care
of the families in our community um with
that I won't go on anymore but I really
do thank you for hearing our story thank
you do I have any
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank you very
much next I have uh
Linette good afternoon and thank you for
taking the time to listen to us my name
is Lyn wette I'm the director in Nellie
treehouse in n in amers New Hampshire
and I've been in the field of Early
Childhood for 41 years um I just want to
take an opportunity to um have an
understanding of why the funds are
needed so recently we just released
re-registration paperwork and in order
to balance giving our staff an annual
raise or allowing our parents to be able
to pay for their child care um instead
of raising our rates to 15% we had to
raise them to eight to try to
balance um parents can't afford to pay
more but these staff deserve to make a
living wage they work hard and they're
taking care of our youngest citizens who
need consistency and love and so having
a fund that would allow us to support
our staff whether it's through their
insurance would be very beneficial not
just to us but to the families of New
Hampshire um and I thank you for taking
time to listen to us thank you
representative PL partially because my
ears are plugged and partially because
you were going fast you were director of
what Treehouse no Nell's treeh house
Nelly
NE yes thank
you anybody else representative ORS
thank you Mr chair thanks for taking my
question so how is the money drawn from
the fund to pay certain employees and
who makes those decisions so at this
point that hasn't been decided like
Jackie said it's just we are in the
process of trying to get this fund set
up so we can make those decisions and
hopefully work with DH HS to determine
what those rules will be and how that
fund will go but it will go to the
employer to help fund maybe insurance or
other benefits for
staff thank you thank
you okay I have two more pink cards I've
got next um Leana
Lorden
good afternoon um my name is Lanna
Lorden and I am the chief operating
officer at White Bird Center in hener um
I've been there for the past 14 years um
and have been in every position there um
and I do appreciate you listening to our
stories um specifically mine will speak
to the workforce um and my tenure in um
the field of early childhood
um we all know the pandemic reinforced
and deepened public understanding of the
essential role of early care and
education working families and the
economy um and ultimately A system that
has been deeply underfunded and
undervalued for example in 2019 the
median wage for childcare workers in New
Hampshire was
$169 for preschool teachers the median
wage is $144 43 cents and New Hampshire
early Educators with a bachelor's degree
are paid
225% less than their colleagues who work
in a K through 8 public um education
school
system that last statistic has always
really resonated with me um not in the
best ways um but because I myself hold a
bachelor's degree in elementary
education um graduating from college
with the hope and dream to be a public
school teacher um it's still something
that I hold current today um but being
um having experienced those lower wages
compared to my colleagues um and even
more so when I began back in this field
in 2010 it was solely because there
weren't any District positions available
I went from teaching um fifth grade in
conquered to not having any District
positions being available so my starting
hourly wage um at White Birch Community
Center was
$9.75 compared to the $20 per hour that
roughly I was making within the public
school sector um so I had to settle um
or so I so I thought for a toddler
classroom teaching position which that
opportunity however held the Silver
Lining um leading me straight to where I
am today um so again this this fund and
um this this bill would really sustain
the workforce that is incredibly
critical for the workforce behind the
workforce thank you for your time and
happy to accept questions thank you any
questions represent
elberger thank you Mr chairman not a
question but a comment I want to thank
you all for coming here I'm I'm a first
turn rep so I understand the the first
time please make sure that you keep in
touch with us and your own legislators
about issues that matter matter to you
because in fact we do listen thanks
thank you thank you representative PL I
try to listen but sometimes you're too
fast for me to keep up typing so you
said something about $111 something pay
repeat the numbers slowly please sure um
so in 2019 the median wage for childcare
workers in the state was $11
69 okay um I do also have written test
Tony that you can have as well if that
helps thank you per would be thank you
thank you okay thank you very much sure
thank
you okay and um the last card I have is
Amanda
Sears good afternoon and thank you
members of the committee for hearing Our
Testimony U my name is Amanda Sears and
I'm the New Hampshire state director for
the campaign for a familyfriendly
economy um I will try not to talk about
the importance of the policy although
that is really hard so I'll try to um
stay on some of the um economic reasons
um to uh Advance this setup for this
policy right now um and I do just want
to add a little bit to some of the
things we've heard about um
representative wner mentioned that um it
is uh very expensive for families to
access Child Care at the moment if you
have two kids under the age of four
right now in the state that's about
$25,000 per year just to give you a
sense of how expensive that is um you
know which for the average working
family can be you know half of a
person's income or more but for the
median person you know and that's just
to get out the door and have your kids
taken care of for the day so that you
can go to work um somebody else
mentioned that this Workforce is the
workforce behind the workforce um and so
every uh person that we have working in
child care that that equates to about
eight families that can go to work and
what is happening right now is that
because of the workforce shortage that
we have in child care centers across the
state almost every Center you speak to
will say that they have empty classrooms
right now and a weight list that is
hundreds of kids long and the reason for
that is the empty classrooms are of
course not because of demand but because
they can't find staff and every
classroom that they have to close means
families that then are looking are
unable to go to work because they don't
have care for their kids or are looking
for unsafe places to put their kids
because they have to get out the door
and go to work and so they end up
leaving their kids in situations that
they wouldn't otherwise considered to be
ideal and so in order to um set up this
fund this is you know it's it's really
uh not just about boosting child care
but it's about ensuring that every
sector in our economy has the workforce
that they need um because as I said one
person in this sector means eight other
people can go to work in the state um
the uh speaker before me referenced uh
some data about wages and you might see
that and I think it was a 2018 or 19
number and think oh that's a long time
ago it's probably inflated a lot since
then I do know that the most recent wage
data which is 2022 data is that it was
$13.78 that the average child care
worker in New Hampshire is making um and
if you think about the inflation and
wages over the past couple of years in
things like retail for example what has
happened because Child Care wages have
not inflated in the same way is that
people are leaving child care to go work
at Dunkin Donuts or at Target or at
Walmart um and are and are really
drawing folks away from the the
workforce sector and so if you look at
the fact that um the current costs for
families are already so high the wages
are so low um and they have all that
competition that's why this kind of a
fund is needed um in terms of setup I
know representative you had asked about
um the sort of rules and the the
mechanism for um getting the resources
into the hands of employees and I think
that while the policy doesn't get into a
lot of detail about that I think that
there are models in the New Hampshire in
other New Hampshire policies that can be
looked at for that um one for example
and I'm sort of policy neutral about
what these different policies are but
just in terms of mechanism um you know
the voucher system for example that's
used in public in um in education for uh
school-aged kids um you know that system
is one system where resources are
getting out to individual families um
who choose to do something other than
the public school sector so there are um
models that you can look at in New
Hampshire policy for this kind of um uh
sort of Quasi or separate from
governmental but you know like a a
system where there is a fund
administrator that administers getting
funds out um to uh individuals for um
for resources you know like this so I
would encourage you to if you believe
that there is more definition needed at
this stage in the policy I think there's
places you could look for for that thank
you thank
you yes representative ORS thank you Mr
chair so thanks for taking my question
yeah so how much are you hoping to raise
the hourly rate for these individuals by
through the fund yeah um that's a good
question and thank you um you know
honestly and enough to be competitive is
the best answer I can give um I I've
neglected to say but in um Maine and
Vermont last year in 2023 both of those
States passed policies to inject
resources um into uh wages for their
childcare workforces and Massachusetts
already had and so um and you know that
the length of our borders means that if
having all three of those states have um
uh boosts to the workforce uh resources
we need to be able to be competitive
with those States so that people don't
just go across the border and work there
which is what's happening now the people
that are that want to stay in the sector
but feel like they can't afford to in
New Hampshire are going across the
border and so I think that we need to
look at um making sure that we can raise
rates to be competitive with those
States and I think that you know um I
believe $5 is sort of the um an extra
five dollar you know um an hour is what
would make us competitive with those
States um because we are so far behind
right now
followup follow up yeah so I I would say
your analysis is correct because I'm
thinking where I live in
chiester route nine that goes through
the
I mean McDonald's The Weather Vein they
they're advertising $18 an hour so I'm
sympathetic to what you're right you
know you're trying to do is just I don't
know how you really solve it maybe this
is an answer
but those kind of jobs are you know who
needs minimum wage when they're paying
$18 an hour and here you folks are
trying to raise it tough situation so
very sympathetic to what you're trying
to do I thank you thank you thank you um
I think if there's no more questions uh
we'll hear from D HHS next thank you
very
much thank you uh I'm Brian Clark uh
general counsel for the division of
economic stability on behalf of DHHS I
have with me Jesse Davis and I am the
bureau chief of Child Development and
headart cl collaboration for
DHHS thank you very much and I'll ask
you both when you're done just fill out
a pink
card or if you already have
great um so I don't know if you guys
want to say something or or you want
questions did you have some initial
statements or well I guess I would just
say we're here to answer questions about
the cost um ultimately we couldn't
determine what the cost would be a
general rule of thumb that we use in
estimating the cost of administering
funds like this is
10% um but since there's no
appropriation or identified funding we
couldn't really give you a number but
we're available for questions okay thank
you representative
leapley thank you um I was just doing
some quick research while the previous
speakers were speaking and it seems
like the federal government is
increasing the block grants um to the
states lately but my assumption is that
that most of the block grants that we
get um it looks like the kind of thing
that supports um families low-income
families can get a subsidy um from the
Department of from DHHS to send their
kids which provides some stability to
the daycare that's accepting right and
some stability to the families but it
seems like the approach here is a little
a little bit different supporting the
daycare provider directly to be able to
support their employees um to keep their
um education up to date to grow their
education so am I right is or does it
look like there might be another source
of federal
funding um that could go
into
uh an account such as the one we're
trying to establish thank
you so um there are opportunities
through the ccdf funding um to support
the workforce um the majority of the
funding goes as you said to eligible
families who are lowincome and require
subsidy to be able to afford the cost of
care so that's a really complex question
if they put more dollars into the ccdf
fund that may expand eligibility for
low-income families but it doesn't
necessarily increase the cost to the
Child Care Program for that slot there's
been a couple of questions about the
cost of care and that's a really
challenging question to answer
nationally and part of that is because
families cannot afford the true cost of
care and so Child Care programs are
charging much less in order to be able
to have families have access to Services
um this year is the first year that a
narrow cost analys is is required by the
federal government to get closer to that
number so that we can understand the
cost of care so this is very complex um
I did have a meeting with the Senator's
office last week talking about the
specific issue of the federal government
needing to call out the childcare
Workforce more
specifically um but at this time there
are no federal dollars specifically
appropriated to the child care Workforce
thank
you yes representative shamberg followed
by represent okay represent
oling I thank you thank you
representative chamber um on your fiscal
note it indicates on the under the
question does this bill provide
sufficient funding to cover estimated
expenditures but you don't know what the
estimated expenditures are so you mark
this
no
what type of
expenditures would you anticipate
if say $10 came in from uh Monopoly
money from the federal
government well so the expenditures
would be
to um contract with a designated entity
to administer the
fund um that's going to be what the
expenditure is
for
and what requirements would this entity
have you'd have to go through the that
process what would the time commitment
be to set up the rules and of as to
who's going to be providing it how it's
going to be provided how it's going to
be administered what what is the time
commitment for that do you have an
estimate of that so Ru making would take
several months the bill is supposed to
be effective January 1st 2025 so uh the
if the bill passes quickly and there's
funding available we will start right
away uh but six months for rule making
would be
aent follow
up if funding is available yes and if
funding is not available we have a
dedicated fund with no money in it that
does nothing
yes representative shamberg all about by
representative duet yes I guess thank
you for taking my question thank you Mr
chairman I guess my question to the
department
is why are all these administered by
third
party and not done
internally
um well the bill before us is
specifically says that the department
will designate a third party uh the
initial draft did have the department
administering the funds
um so the reason it says that is because
the committee drafted it that
way representative
duet thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question I I we heard some
testimony there was some $15 million
that uh the department received last
year is this going to leave a void if
and we also heard testimony that those
$15 million would if this fund was
established would be shifted over there
I'm I'm I'm wondering whether it's going
to leave a void 15 million was spent on
something and I know it wasn't some of
these I'm guessing it's not one of these
specifics that are laid out in this
piece of legislation and how are you
going to back fill that Gap with those
dollars that you received so the15
million appropriation we are calling the
childcare Workforce Grant that
application period closed February 23rd
and the department is going through
applications in that process right now
and many of the same um expenses can be
used um that are written in this bill
for that funding as well um by the time
this fund got
Appropriations allocated to it that 15
million would be expended follow up so I
I probably misunderstood so it's a
one-time Grant you rece
yes representative Le Lee thank you Mr
chair thanks for taking a question
um
are I'm assuming that you're reviewing
applications but you already have
parameters of of what you think are
appropriate um ways to spend that money
um does it do some of those overlap with
what we're discussing here or are they
different and can you kind of enumerate
some of those just so we can understand
um differences and overlaps and then
another question is it sounds like
you're administering the $15
million the department is administering
the $15 million and unfortunately I did
not come prepared with all of the ways
that you can spend the current Grant
dollars but they are very similar and um
we will know um J July 2024 is the first
reporting period on the $15 million
funds to know how those um funds were
used for those programs so we at this
point don't have information to
share represent me yeah thank you
um I've got two things but on one of
them is on this so I want to stay on it
on there is no way that you are allowed
to use part of this 15 million to get
the rules written so that you can start
the other program is that correct
correct so you aren't going to do it
unless someone will give you
money if this bill passes I believe that
then we would have to solve the problem
of getting the rules written and how we
would administer the program whether it
would be with a third party entity
whether it would be the department I
can't answer that question specifically
at this
time
so there are a couple of things in this
bill that you
have already said um
you or just said you didn't want might
not want to do but they're in the bills
so you'd have to if we passed it one of
them is that
on handing it over to an independent
entity and the other one is this
business about an eligible individual
employee uh that that can't get his
employer to do it and you
seem you seem to be
uh on you would have to work directly
with these eligible individual
employees and it looks like it would
have to be outside of that other
designated
entity so um I'm not quite sure how that
one works and whether you would want us
to change some of the
language or how can we make sure that
this thing can get
done um yes that's correct so when I
read that I was my understanding was
that if an eligible employee applied for
funding to do um let's say tuition
assistance for professional education
and the employer didn't want participate
for some reason um the employee could
apply directly to the department instead
of the designated entity uh for funding
and so the impact of that is really too
difficult to determine um we we could do
it uh we would need to write
administrative rules on how you apply um
where the funding how we would be able
to draw down from that um
but we're not sure what percentage of
employees would have to go that route if
any follow up thank you do you have some
idea of what the
um the difficulties might be for
instance let's take all of the um
garages in New
Hampshire on most of of them are are
three to six employees I think maybe
they go up to
10 and that could
be a lot of bureaucratic work for them
that they aren't really equipped to
handle of course only one or two
probably per garage would have
kids so um but that's a lot of
individuals who could apply as I
understand it as an
individual
employee and you'd be responsible for
them I'm I'm unsure of the question but
yes there are some complexities in this
bill that um would need to have careful
consideration during Ru making um I
think that I I was ask the special
committee on child care when they added
that it it went over about an hour um
and I think the intent of this bill is
to really support the
workforce
and if an
employer did not want to opt into this
opportunity they didn't want the
employees to not have that benefit and
so this was the way that they were
trying to um ensure that the child care
workers had access to this
fund yes but could you handle
it I will say that we would need more
employees for the complexity
of of this particular
fund who represent spilburg
am I correctly understanding that the
only employers we're talking about here
who can apply are daycare employers
we're not talking about employers around
the economy or employers of people who
have children in daycare we're talking
about people who employ daycare
workers yes so um it says Child Care
programs operating with an Active Child
Care license or that are license exempt
and enrolled in the Department of Health
and Human Services child care
scholarship program that's about 600
programs out of the 700ish that are in
New
Hampshire repres fellows thank you Mr
chair I'm just wondering if um the since
the source of funds for this could be
any private state or federal
money that maybe you're what it can be
used for needs to include some kind of
flexibility to it because you know a
private donation or federal federal
money you don't they're going to tell
you they're going to tell you how they
think the money ought to be spent and
and my the other question is when money
comes in from federal and private
sources is it going to be clear when it
should go into this fund versus versus
maybe some other programs you already
have at your agency related to child
care So currently for the workforce we
really only have
one funding stream that is not um
Affiliated from the state and so uh
that's somewhat of a complex question
for me to answer um because I didn't
write this bill but I assume that that
the anybody any private donor investing
money in this fund would understand that
it would go to the childcare Workforce
for these
reasons seeing no more questions thank
you very
much is there anyone else who would like
to testify on hb1 1611
seeing none I'm going to close the
public
hearing so um thank you everyone that
that concludes today's uh agenda
tomorrow as you know we are meeting
starting at 9:30 we have a work session
and then at 1:00 uh no
1:30 um we have our exec session and um
as for next week um I'm going to
schedule Monday I don't know yet whether
when Wednesday is necessary but um at
least Monday at this point and possibly
Wednesday Tuesday is election day so we
won't be having any anything else thank
you you know how to clear a room Mr
[Laughter]
chairman